ich heiße maroni
denn in spanien geboren und bin derzeit
bei der dritten garde company machen ein
großer verdienst
ich bin zum österreichischen boni sehr
jungen ja aus dankbarkeit und dass ich
den österreichischen volk und land
österreich etwas zurückgeben kann se für
meine familie getan hatten und haben uns
herzlich aufgenommen als wir aus dem
knick gekommen sind
und ja bei uns kennen ist es halt eine
sache der ehre
man vergisst nichts gutes ein gutes wird
minuten vergolden wenn nicht noch besser
[Musik]
endlich kann ich mich erinnern
ich erinnere mich an die geräusche an
die
die schießereien
an die panzer die vorbeifahren an die
hubschrauber als dreijährige kann man
also nicht sehr gut verstehen wo man hat
schon ein gefühl ich habe das jetzt
stimmt unser haus wurde vom hubschrauber
beschossen
und dann hat mein bruder eine
schusswunde erlebten dann klickt in
österreich fühlen würde wenn
verteidigungskrieg
[Musik]
ja natürlich meine eltern sind stolz
darauf jetzt bin ich dran bleiben ja
bestehen ist meine heimat da bin ich
geboren und da kommen eine vorväter seit
hunderten jahren und ein ganzes leben
habe ich in österreich gelebt und mit
drei es auch männer haben in österreich
zu leben ist schön
ein privileg
freiheit
tja was kann man in österreich nicht
mehr